hey guys it's eddie here with alessandro
we both got a hands-on recently for a
pre-release demo
of crash bandicoot 4. it's about time
and and we're here to talk to you about
you know what we saw what we liked and
more so you know let's dive right in all
right so crash bandicoot 4
is a direct sequel to crash 3 which was
you know the original trilogy games made
by naughty dog
and in this game you're picking up with
you know obviously you're playing as
crash again but they're introducing a
number of other different playable
characters such as dr neocortex you know
the evil
villain from the earlier games so you
get to play as him later in this game
and we could probably talk about that
more later
so yeah this uh this game is actually
going back to basics like uh you know
it's
uh this is crash bandicoot 4 not like uh
some other like sort of
weird subtitle that they put in for the
other sequels this is actually a more
direct sequel to
crash bandicoot 3 warped it was
interesting going back to this because
you know i have a fondness for those
games but i think revisiting now is just
like
for one they just seem to sort of have
like this purity when it comes to
platforming and
you know just it's just really easy to
get into but it's also very
very difficult pretty quickly too so did
you notice like oh how challenging that
was oh absolutely so like one of the
things that they were
the developers were talking about is how
you know this game has you know tense
and precise
platforming and like that's absolutely
true i definitely struggled
um with a few of the levels at the
beginning it's definitely uh you know a
learning process but it all feels like
fair
like you never feel like the game is you
know against you or in any way
you know cheating you out of achieving
something it's all about learning which
ways to go which paths to take
and you know being able to execute the
specific platforming objectives that are
in front of you
and we were actually playing on the sort
of the the modern mode gameplay mode
they had the retro mode which actually
brought back the sort of like the
the lives like player lives that you
know every time you die you lose a life
and stuff but
for the modern mode you just go back to
the checkpoint but uh in the top right
corner it sort of keeps track of all the
times like you know you died
it's almost sort of like you know a
puzzle platformer in
a way especially when you work in some
of the new masks uh that this game has
so if we want to talk about those like
talk about the um you know the time
stopping mask for a crash that he uses
and i thought that was a really
unique uh way to you know mix things up
in terms of
you know the puzzle solving there were a
lot of different mechanics tied to
being able to stop time that you know
didn't immediately click with me
at the start but then you know you see
through trial and error you could figure
out how to get through the levels
i got to say it like blended really well
with like the sort of like the core
like you know actual platforming and
jumping mechanics of the game and uh you
know it was pretty interesting seeing
you know uh that that sort of like you
know new
ability being brought in but uh also
there's another one like in the other
level too which was
sort of like this uh sort of like phase
shifting like mask
you click the button to you know
initiate the phase and you know the
world kind of just flips
and yeah you know you see a different
perspective and it you know unlocks
different objectives and
you know kind of going off that in the
um in that dino dash level
um yeah obviously i think i think that
was my favorite of the three that we got
to play
especially because of those you know the
classic crash moments when you're you
know
you're running you know toward the
camera yeah with a dinosaur chasing you
down and you know i mean i
like i didn't i mean it was kind of
difficult to you know get those
uh get the timing and the jumps and the
slides you know try to coordinate all
those in the right way
and then like if you were like
unsuccessful there's some pretty brutal
animations i don't know if this happened
oh yeah yeah when the t-rex eats you
it brought back those like similar
feelings of like you know that sort of
like anxiousness but also that rush
it was a it was really nice to you know
sort of experience that again but like
in a new game
yeah yeah i i think they've done a good
job here at least in the sections which
uh that we played which again you know
our pre-release code um
they've done a good job at you know like
making you know taking crash and
taking its you know foundations in you
know gaming nostalgia and kind of you
know
modernizing it you know we actually also
get to play uh as a
cortex as well you actually revisit past
levels and you know you actually sort of
change the flow of like you know the
events of that level and um
the one level we got to play as him was
actually revisit the first level in the
demo and
uh you actually sort of like alter like
a
an event that happens in that level and
um from there you actually switch back
to crash and you sort of
continue the course of that level but
it's a bit different and it's actually
like way harder too so yeah i mean i
really liked his
you know his special abilities too his
blaster gun and you know the way he
could you know make things into jelly or
you know rock to jump on and
you know going back to your other point
too i thought the way they're
introducing story or you know additional
elements of story in this through that
is very very interesting because in the
dyno dash level too we saw a section
where
you know crash was you know he was saved
by you know by someone but we didn't see
who it was and that's kind of similar to
this
snow way out mission where um you know a
cinematic plays out but you don't have
all the information but then you play as
cortex and you kind of figure out what
happened so i think that's a really
interesting way to deliver story
it was fun to see that sort of like like
that that character brought back again
but also to play as him as well like um
you know then
it's a nice compliment to sort of the
traditional levels too because like
he's not as agile but you know he's got
like other tricks and stuff he can use
so it was pretty it was a nice change of
place
playing as himself yeah it definitely
was like he doesn't have a
he doesn't have a double jump he has a
dash but he doesn't have a double jump
so yeah it's it really creates a
you know fun new way to play it oh
definitely and uh one other thing that's
actually
uh coming to this game as well that we
didn't quite see in the demo but that
coco will actually have more of a
of a presence in this game as well like
him from what i they said um they you
can actually play as coco
in pretty much every crash level uh as
well
so uh that should be uh pretty
interesting like you know just being
able to swap
between the two like you know as you
want i mean something else that we
should probably talk about too is like
the
probably the incredible amount of
replayability you might find in these
levels in terms of you know collecting
all the wimpos and finding all the
easter eggs like
i don't know about you but i didn't get
close to getting you know the hundreds
um in so i could see myself going back
and
you know it would definitely be
challenging but i would love to watch
someone speedrun this game or you know
100
and i think that'd be really fun to see
one thing i will say and um
that you know i really appreciate it's a
really subtle change too but
there's like a circle right underneath
crash
so you can actually see where you're
landing and uh
that wasn't in the original games so
that's like something i really
appreciate because like i think the
challenge that a lot of people face is
like sort of
getting a sense of like you know
distance when you're trying to make the
platforming
like you know like jumps and stuff so um
i i really like some of like the subtle
changes like being added to the game but
which still feel very consistent with
like the original trilogy
yeah i mean in particular there were you
know plenty of platforms i just would
not have made it to if it weren't for
that
for sure yeah all right that's it from
me and alessandro here talking about
crash bandicoot 4. it's about time you
can check out the game for yourself on
october 2nd
for ps4 and xbox one and let us know
what you think of the game in the
comments below
see you next time
you